this video was made possible by
curiosity stream
sign up for the nebula bundle deal on
sale for 15 a year
to get access to two great streaming
sites and help support independent
creators
at curiositystream.com wendover
covid19 a virus orders of magnitude
smaller than a particle of dust
has turned daily life on earth into
something deeply
unfamiliar in the 10 or so months since
it first emerged
the virus has settled at a steady clip
of killing 5
000 people per day or nearly a million
total
currently it has played havoc with the
world economy
plunging the globe into the worst
economic crisis since world war
ii it has interrupted an era of mountain
globalization
and pushed us into a more insular
nationalistic state
the effects of this virus are truly all
encompassing
and consistently dreadful but time has
bestowed upon us
a reward for our patients we are
potentially nearing the beginning of the
end
meaning we could now be at the end of
the middle
that end of this virus will take far
longer than the beginning
we're likely far from halfway through
the pandemic in terms of time
but the slow decline in dreadfulness is
potentially
on the horizon that's because a vaccine
is coming there was previously a period
of doubt on whether an effective vaccine
could be developed
it was never a sure shot but all
indications currently suggest
given the unprecedented extent of
scientific effort
that it is indeed coming the only
and paramount question is when
right now in september 2020 all
attention is focused on the late october
early november time frame that's the
earliest possible moment when any of the
frontrunner vaccines
from major manufacturers including
astrazeneca pfizer and moderna
could enter regulatory review if all the
data
confidently point to the vaccine
exhibiting an acceptable level of safety
and effectiveness
it is possible that one of these will
then be granted emergency use
authorization
by the american fda or its equivalent by
other major national regulators it's
worth noting that this is far from a
sure shot
but experts do say that having a vaccine
in 2020
is a less than long shot possibility
however
it is almost certain that you will not
be injected
by a covid19 vaccine in the year 2020.
it is possible but for the average
person
when you actually get a dose of a
coveted vaccine has much
less to do with when it's approved and
much more with how
fast it is manufactured and distributed
the
full effects of the pandemic health
social and economic
will not end until a critical mass of
people are
vaccinated that means that when we get
back to normal life
has much more to do with when the last
person is vaccinated
rather than the first this is why some
have said that the fast distribution of
a vaccine will be an even
greater challenge than the development
itself this process
this challenge of getting the majority
of the world's population vaccinated
can quite legitimately be described as
the most daunting
and consequential single logistical
challenge ever
the stakes have never been higher but
the challenge
has also never been greater let's look
at why first and foremost it's a scale
problem
shipping and administering one vaccine
to one person is not difficult
but shipping and administering 5 billion
vaccines to 5 billion
people is that's because there just
isn't enough room in our world's
logistics network
as it is now to do that making it even
tougher
there's more chance than not based on
the current leading vaccines
that the first major vaccine to be
approved will require two doses
administered 21 or 28 days apart
that doubles the challenge distributing
10 or more billion doses of vaccine
would be difficult enough in normal
times
but these are far from normal times with
international travel all but
non-existent
currently sitting at more than 90 down
passenger airlines have dramatically cut
back
their international route networks now
this
is an issue because traditionally some
50 of pharmaceuticals are shipped in the
belly hold of passenger aircraft
rather than on dedicated freighters as
this can help them get closer to their
final destination
faster with limited passenger service
overall cargo capacity is down about
30 percent while cargo demand is only
about 15
down meaning there is already a supply
crunch
this has led to existing dedicated
freighter aircraft being used more
additional dedicated freighters coming
into service but still due to
constrained supply
a dramatic increase in shipping costs
even already
before the coveted vaccine comes into
the global logistics network
pharmaceutical manufacturers have had to
come up with new techniques to ship
their goods
including for example flying their
product to where shipping rates are
cheaper
and trucking them to their final
destination or chartering private planes
of course the world already experienced
a massive logistics challenge this year
with the distribution of personal
protective equipment
and shippers were able to scale up for
that reasonably successfully
but there's one simple reason why it
won't be so easy this time around
the cold chain vaccines are temperature
sensitive most all of them have to be
stored in a highly precise
climate-controlled environment in order
to stay safe and effective
so the cold chain is the supply chain
suited to shipping goods that need to be
kept cold or frozen
such as meat chemicals and
pharmaceuticals of course the difficulty
with the cold chain is that
everything used has to be specialized
the origin warehouse the truck the plane
the in-route warehouse
and the final destination each need to
have the equipment to keep the goods at
the specified temperature
or the goods have to be shipped in
packaging that keeps them at the
specified temperature
both options are complicated and
complication compounded by other
complication
is what makes a true logistical
challenge
it doesn't end there though one of the
leading vaccine candidates
pfizer's bnt 162 b2 must be stored and
transported at around negative 90
degrees fahrenheit
or negative 68 degrees celsius that is
far far colder than the requirements of
most vaccines which can ship either at
refrigerated temperatures
or a wider range of freezing
temperatures a
thermal requirement such as this is a
whole different ball game
and it means that they'll be able to use
only a subset of cold chain
infrastructure which is already a subset
of overall logistics infrastructure
beyond the issue of actually getting
such a vaccine to a distribution site
most hospitals don't even have
facilities to keep a vaccine at such a
temperature
let alone clinics or pharmacies meaning
that even finding places that can
receive this vaccine
is a challenge part of the reason why
this obstacle has come up is that
traditionally
vaccines are thoroughly tested to
determine what sort of storage and
shipping conditions they can endure
while still staying safe and effective
but with the breakneck pace of
development for these coveted 19
vaccines
there likely will not have been enough
time to conduct these tests before
distribution
meaning they'll have to keep the
standards at what's already proven
so to reiterate already a likely vaccine
will only be able to be shipped through
a subset
of a subset of a subset of an already
strained logistics network
to a subset of sites and it'll need to
happen many
billions of times but even the solution
to these challenges
present additional challenges pfizer for
example
knowing that the unique distribution
requirements of their vaccine could
limit its commercial success
has developed a partial solution it's
essentially a highly specialized
standalone box that can
with the use of dry ice keep the vaccine
at the required temperature for up to 10
days this means that hypothetically the
vaccine could be shipped through a more
traditional logistics network
however this box has highly specific
requirements
for one upon arrival it can only be
opened twice per day
not more than one minute at a time in
order to keep the vaccines at the
required temperature
that means that a distribution site
would need to accurately predict how
many doses they would need in a given
day before
that day if they take out too little
they'd be slowing the process by not
vaccinating everyone they can
but if they take out too much they'd
have potentially life-saving vaccines go
to waste at the end of the day
also this box can only carry vaccines in
multiples of a thousand
and keep in mind that it only keeps cold
for 10 days
so how for example do you go about
getting the vaccine to a clinic that can
only vaccinate 50 people in a day
like a rural clinic in a small town even
if shipping was instantaneous
they could only vaccinate 500 people in
10 days
meaning half their vaccines would go bad
pfizer is apparently developing a
smaller temperature controlled box to
solve this problem
but that means adding a whole other type
of distribution which increases
complexity
which slows the process down in its
scenario planning
the american cdc mapped out a
distribution process
for if both pfizer and modernist
vaccines are approved
and if this happened the pfizer vaccine
would be directed to only large
distribution sites that would either
have the facilities for ultra-cold
storage
or the capacity to vaccinate enough
people that the short shelf life of
these vaccines wouldn't be an
issue then the madarina vaccine which
only requires traditional freezer
temperatures
would be directed to smaller sites with
less advanced facilities
this would certainly create a scenario
in the u.s and likely elsewhere where
the pfizer vaccine would be primarily
distributed to people in cities
while the madarina vaccine would be the
vaccine of choice for rural areas
another challenge that needs to be
confronted is the order of operations
for distribution
the coronavirus affects different people
in different ways
this means that if we want a vaccine to
save the most number of lives possible
the first person in line should be that
who is most susceptible to covet 19
and the last person in line should be
that who is least susceptible
one set of research models two scenarios
the first where of the first three
billion doses available
50 high-income countries buy up 2
billion of them
the second was where the first 3 billion
doses were distributed to countries
proportionally based on their population
regardless of wealth in this model twice
as many people died overall with the
first scenario
the wealthy country's first scenario
than the equitable
proportional approach however for
vaccination purposes
it is the least wealthy countries
arguably those that need the vaccine
most
that are toughest to distribute to poor
countries
tend to have limited cold chain
infrastructure let alone normal
logistics infrastructure
and fragmented poorly funded healthcare
systems distributing and administering a
complex vaccine like pfizers will
already be tough enough in the wealthy
countries like the united states
but just imagine how difficult it will
be to get a vaccine from distributor to
someone's arm
in rural democratic republic of the
congo for example in 10 days
while keeping it at negative 90 degrees
fahrenheit
how soon a coveted vaccine is
administered will quite directly
correlate to how many lives are saved
every day of delay will with certainty
lead to more death
and despair the manufacturers are
working as fast as they can they are
already producing millions of doses of
their vaccines before they are approved
so they can be distributed as fast as
possible
and regulatory agencies have been
preparing for months for an
unprecedentedly fast review process
so it is now truly down to every member
of the global logistics network
to save lives of course many of those
that will be involved
especially once we get to wide scale
distribution will be companies
not governments or non-profits and for
them this presents
a massive business opportunity in
addition to the positive public
relations potential
ups for example has built two freezer
farms in louisville kentucky and venlo
netherlands near their hubs
which can each hold 48 000 doses and can
go down to the temperatures required for
the pfizer vaccine
dhl and fedex 2 are reportedly massively
upscaling their cold chain
infrastructure
to be able to handle some of the surge
in demand while other lesser-known
logistics companies
are too ultimately though it's tough to
find someone
in the know who doesn't admit that
shipping will
be a bottleneck we already know it's not
going to go perfectly
so right now it's about doing as much
work as possible
to make sure the process goes as well as
it can be
this will come down to making sure that
as much planning work as possible is
done now
before the vaccine is approved so that
distribution can happen as fast as
possible when
that does happen now is the time to
figure out how
and where the vaccine will be
distributed if you are a healthy
relatively young person of thinking
selfishly you should care
tremendously about the distribution
process because you
are at the back of the line when you get
your shot
when you get to start letting your guard
down has everything to do
with how fast everyone in front of you
gets theirs
and how fast they get theirs will also
impact how many of them
will die we know this process will not
be perfect
and it wouldn't be reasonable to ask for
perfect given the complexity of the
challenge
but if we truly put every effort into
planning and preparing for this now
and create a system that orders people
by need rather than wealth
we can at least know at the end of this
that no lives could have been saved
if only the vaccine got to them faster
for our collective consciousness looking
back far in the future
this moment will be defined not by when
we get to go back to concerts or
parties or the gym but rather by how
many lives we saved when confronting
what is hopefully the greatest global
challenge of this
generation as you've heard before
the point of nebula the streaming site
that i and other independent creators
founded
is to make a greater variety of content
types possible
for example i know many of you were fans
of my and brian from real engineering's
old podcast showmakers
where we interviewed different
educational creators about their
background story and process
but the financials of that show just
didn't work so we stopped it
nebula however has made it possible for
us to relaunch it
so we've done exactly that showmakers
is now a nebula original podcast
this is an addition to the two wendover
originals we've done already
the half as interesting original and
another wendover original that is coming
out next month of course
the best way to get access to nebula is
curiosity stream's bundle deal
on sale now for 15 a year with that
you also get access to curiosity stream
where you could watch for example
the piece they made about how the
development of the coveted vaccine works
filmed with the actual scientists
involved that's of course
in addition to the thousands of other
educational shows and documentaries they
have
and together with nebula this represents
truly the best
deal in streaming sign up today for the
bundle deal for just 15
a year with current sale pricing at
curiositystream.com
wendover